Josh it's lovely to see you here tonight
for the premiere a penny dreadful now of
course we bring classic literary
characters and classic monsters to life
in this particular series how do you
keep it fresh and exciting both for
yourself as an actor and also for the
audience well for myself I can always
say that when you went anytime I take on
a character I try to look at his
character really exists and I don't want
to do the character disservice of just
playing it like any other character that
I've played before so I want to study up
on what what he could be going through
and and what it is that makes that that
is impacted that impassioned him and
what it is that he's afraid of him how
he how he grows throughout the series
all these things are really important
what makes this show fresh is you know
John Logan's writing one bayonne is
directing and Sam's producing and
hopefully our performances are not too
stale so it's just it's just a it's just
a it's just a measure of the people
involved that makes this a fresh show
you play a smart talking American
sharpshooter in the show who gets
involved with eben greens character and
Timothy Dawson's character it's all very
mysterious and you're kind of kept in
the dark aren't you how much as an actor
do you like to have that mysterious
sight both your character and when
you're taking on a new project yourself
for me it's not so much about keeping
mystery involved in my in my own life as
it is about keeping my own life my own
so if I do if I ever came across
mysterious it's just that I'm you know
I'm just trying to keep my life mine now
the great characters in the show based
new characters like yourself and of
course characters like Frankenstein
we've got with Harry Treadaway
and what do you enjoy about that kind of
horror genre that's supernatural world
which of course you've made films in
that genre for having it well you know
what I what I enjoy about this show in
particular is that that when it takes
all of these different characters which
are allegories for our own four
personality types of things that we want
to achieve I think that these characters
are
are necessary parts of kind of the
expression of what it means to be I
don't know a person with secrets in the
modern age and and so I responded to
this purely because of the writing and
because the collaborators involved I
haven't have been drawn to a couple of
supernatural things thirty days thirty
days tonight being the most recent I
guess because they that one in
particular because it reminded me of
hearts of darkness so a heart of
darkness which was then made into
Apocalypse Now and you know he's a great
book by Joseph Conrad and it had this
this element of of people left to their
own devices madness and and and and just
that overriding sort of fear of the
unknown and and each you know each
project is different I respond to them
for different reasons if you could bring
any literary character the screen
yourself and whether it be horror or not
he would you like to bring to screen who
would you like to play as well someone
asked me this earlier and I was trying
to figure out which like British author
really really had characters that
inspired something in me and I remember
when I was seventeen years old
Trainspotting came out and I started
reading Irving Welsh and I thought
basically any one of those any any
character and everyone else's novels
would be something that would be so far
removed from Who I am
it'd be fun to at least give it a go but
maybe maybe just at home alone I don't
know if anybody would take me seriously
is Begbie or something know you
mentioned early a little bit about
parallels with modern life what kind of
parallels you see between the world in
penny dreadful which is set late 1800s
Victorian England and modern day life
there's so many parallels so that's the
thing that's interesting about this show
is that and I think the book that we
used John used as sort of a template for
creating the world of this show which is
Matthew sweets inventing inventing the
Victorians it's a it's kind of we've
been misled by you know the direct the
the direct descendants of the Victorians
the Bloomsbury group that basically said
you know everything in the Victorian era
was antiquated and stayed and buttoned
and they didn't have any fun they were
afraid of sex and all these things
it wasn't exactly true so it's a now
that we're sort of looking at looking at
it a little bit more clearly or
digging things up or reading Matthew
sweets book we have a sense that people
haven't changed much just the
circumstances a bit and but it there is
a there is a so I guess there are quite
a few millions of things that that keep
that are similar between us and and the
Victorians and at the time the
unfortunate thing is we don't have a lot
of films so like you can go back and
look at it all you have is is
second-hand accounts you know accounts
by writers of course you're working with
a big fund team on this film I'm John
Logue of the Skyfall who created it and
written it Sam Mendes director of
Skyfall and the Future Fund movies as
well as well as John Logan Eva Green who
is in Casino Royale but Timothy Dalton
who was bond now do you see yourself in
a role in a future Bond movie well I'm
an Americans so the only thing opened to
me as a villain I think or a Bond girl
but I don't think that's what kind of
villain do you think it's like what kind
of villain
I mean surprising kind I don't know what
is there is there there's a particular
type of villain I don't if I can throw a
hat takes people's heads off that'd be
I'd be a bonus
you